[Applaudissements]
la date est une mamie y est on a
toujours l'impression qu'à morgan
freeman même quand il est pas mon globe
à
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde s'est excusé mais tout ça
pas dans des zones chaudes parce que je
sors de ton âge
ouais j'ai pris mon vélo je suis arrivé
direct et j'ai fait partie des excuses
en syrie non mais je sais c'est demain
toi on n'est pas bien j'en ai marre dit
mardi
j'ai passé j'ai pas de cachet pour tous
ou presque pas de cachet ja je passe
plus faire quelque chose pour les flics
j'ai grillé un feu tout est inquiète pas
non là quand on fait de mal
et ça c'est cet ingénieur à l'écart ans
et le consul de ariel la petite sirène
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi